(Video: el controlador de tráfico aéreo dirige el tráfico)
Este es nuestro controlador de tránsito aéreo que llama
al aeropuerto internacional de Kigali.
Y cuando el zip llega al hospital,
desciende a unos 9 m y deja caer el paquete.
Usamos un paracaídas de papel muy simple. Las cosas simples son las mejores.
Eso permite que el paquete llegue al suelo de forma suave y confiable
en el mismo lugar todo el tiempo.
Es como compartir el viaje;
los médicos reciben un mensaje un minuto antes de que lleguemos, que dice:
"Salga y reciba su entrega".
(Risa)
Y entonces...
(Aplausos)
luego los médicos tienen lo necesario para salvar la vida de un paciente.
Esto es la vista de una entrega desde nuestro centro de distribución;
este vehículo está a unos 50 km de distancia.
Podemos ver el vehículo mientras realiza una entrega en un hospital
en tiempo real.
Quizá hayan notado que hay pings, rastreadores de paquetes en redes,
que salen de ese vehículo en la pantalla.
Esos pings son, en realidad, paquetes de datos
que usan las redes de telefonía móvil.
Estos aviones tienen tarjetas SIM al igual que un teléfono móvil,
y se comunican a través de la red móvil
para decirnos dónde y cómo están en todo momento.
Lo crean o no, en realidad, compramos planes familiares
(Risas)
para esta flota de vehículos,
porque así es como obtenemos las mejores tarifas.
(Risas)
En realidad, no es una broma.
Así que en la actualidad entregamos un 20 %
del suministro nacional de sangre de Ruanda
fuera de Kigali.
Servimos a unos 12 hospitales,
y estamos agregando hospitales a esa red a un ritmo acelerado.
Todos esos hospitales solo reciben sangre de esta manera,
y la mayoría de esos hospitales hacen pedidos múltiples todos los días.
Entonces la razón
en toda la logística del cuidado de la salud,
siempre se intercambia desperdicio por acceso.
Si se quiere resolver lo del desperdicio, hay que mantener todo centralizado.
Como resultado, cuando los pacientes tienen emergencias,
a veces no tienen el producto médico que necesitan.
Si se quiere resolver el acceso, hay muchos medicamentos en el último km,
en hospitales o centros de salud,
y así los pacientes tienen los medicamentos que necesitan.
Pero se terminan tirando muchos medicamentos,
que es muy caro
Lo sorprendente es que el gobierno de Ruanda ha sido capaz
de romper este ciclo de forma permanente.
Porque los médicos pueden obtener lo que necesitan al instante,
en realidad, almacenan menos sangre en los hospitales.
Y, aunque el uso de productos sanguíneos ha aumentado sustancialmente
en todos los hospitales que atendemos,
en los últimos nueve meses, cero unidades de sangre han expirado
en cualquiera de estos hospitales.
(Aplausos)
Ese es un resultado sorprendente.
Eso en realidad no se ha logrado en ningún otro sistema de atención médica
en el planeta,
y sucedió aquí.
Pero obviamente, cuando hablamos de entregar productos médicos al instante,
lo más importante son los pacientes.
Les daré un ejemplo.
Hace un par de meses, una madre de 24 años entró en uno de los hospitales
a los que atendemos,
y dio a luz por cesárea.
Y eso llevó a complicaciones y comenzó a sangrar.
Afortunadamente, los médicos tenían sangre de su tipo sanguíneo a mano
que se había entregado mediante el servicio de Zipline,
y le transfundieron un par de unidades de sangre.
Pero ella sangró esas unidades en unos 10 minutos.
En este caso la vida de esa madre estaría en grave peligro
en cualquier hospital del mundo.
Pero afortunadamente, los médicos que la cuidaban
llamaron de inmediato a nuestro centro de distribución,
emitiendo un pedido de emergencia,
y nuestro equipo hizo entrega de emergencia tras entrega de emergencia,
tras entrega de emergencia.
Al final se enviaron siete unidades de glóbulos rojos,
cuatro unidades de plasma
y dos unidades de plaquetas.
Eso es más sangre de la que tienes en todo tu cuerpo.
Toda se le transfundió a ella,
los médicos pudieron estabilizarla,
y ella está sana hoy.
(Aplausos)
Desde que empezamos, hemos realizado unas 400 entregas de emergencia como esa,
y hay una historia como esa detrás de la mayoría de esas emergencias.
Aquí hay solo un par de las mamás
que han recibido transfusiones de esta manera
en los últimos meses.
Siempre nos recuerdan: al ayudar a un médico a salvar la vida de una madre,
no es solo su vida lo que estás salvando,
también se salva la vida de un bebé o una beba
que tiene una madre mientras crece.
(Aplausos)
Pero quiero ser claro:
la hemorragia posparto no es un problema de Ruanda,
no es un problema del mundo en desarrollo,
es un problema global.
La salud materna es un desafío en todas partes.
La principal diferencia es que Ruanda fue el primer país
en usar tecnología radical para hacer algo al respecto.
Y esa es la razón por la cual esta actitud de que en África
no funcione la tecnología avanzada
o de que necesitan ayuda
es totalmente errónea.
África puede ser el disruptor.
Estas economías pequeñas, ágiles y en desarrollo
pueden superar la innovación de las grandes y ricas.
Y pueden superar por completo la ausencia de infraestructura heredada
y lanzarse directamente a sistemas nuevos y mejores.
En 2000, si alguien hubiera dicho
que las redes móviles de alta calidad estaban a punto
de desplegarse en toda África,
la gente habría dicho que estábamos locos.
Y, sin embargo, nadie anticipó
lo rápido que esas redes se conectarían y empoderarían a las personas.
Hoy el 44 % del PIB de Kenia fluye a través de M-Pesa,
su plataforma de pago móvil.
Y no solo eso, también
nuestra flota autónoma de vehículos se basa en esa red móvil.
En los próximos años a medida que prestemos
servicios privados de atención médica,
también usaremos esa plataforma de pago móvil
para cobrar tarifas por entregas.
Y la innovación lleva a mayor innovación y a más innovación.
Y, mientras tanto,
la mayoría de las personas que viven en economías desarrolladas
piensa que la entrega de drones es tecnológicamente imposible,
y más imposible que suceda a escala nacional en el este de África.
Y me refiero al este de África, no solo a Ruanda.
El jueves, hace solo un par de días,
el Ministerio de Salud de Tanzania
anunció que van a usar esta misma tecnología
para proporcionar una entrega instantánea de una amplia gama de productos médicos
a 10 millones de las personas con más difícil acceso en el país.
(Aplausos)
En realidad, va a ser el sistema autónomo más grande del mundo.
Para darles una idea de cómo se ve esto,
este es uno de los primeros centros de distribución.
Puede ver un radio de servicio de 75 km alrededor del centro de distribución,
y eso nos permite servir a cientos de centros de salud y hospitales,
todos ellos rurales,
desde ese centro de distribución único.
Pero para servir a más del 20 % de la población de Tanzania,
vamos a necesitar varios centros de distribución,
realmente necesitaremos cuatro.
Y desde estos centros de distribución,
esperamos hacer cientos de entregas de salvamento todos los días,
y este sistema finalmente dará servicio a más de 1000 instalaciones de salud
y hospitales en el país.
Así que sí, el este de África se mueve muy rápido.
Una cosa que las personas, a menudo, no saben
es que este tipo de saltos generan ganancias capitalizables.
Ruanda, al invertir en esta infraestructura del cuidado de salud,
ahora tiene una red de logística aérea que puede usar
para catalizar otras partes de su economía,
como la agricultura o el comercio electrónico.
Aún más importante, el 100 % de los equipos
que contratamos en estos centros de distribución son locales.
Así que aquí está nuestro equipo de Ruanda,
que es un grupo de ingenieros y operadores extraordinarios.
Manejan el único sistema de entrega automatizado del mundo
que opera a escala nacional.
Han sido capaces de dominar algo
que las empresas de tecnología más grandes del mundo
todavía no han podido descifrar.
Son héroes totales.
(Aplausos)
La misión de nuestro equipo es brindar acceso básico a la medicina
a los 7000 millones de personas del planeta,
no importa cuán difícil sea alcanzarlos.
A menudo contamos a la gente sobre esa misión,
y dicen: "Eso es muy generoso de su parte, es muy filantrópico".
¡No!
La filantropía no tiene nada que ver con eso.
Debido a los contratos comerciales que firmamos con ministerios de salud,
estas redes son 100 % sostenibles y expandibles.
Y la razón para sentirnos tan enojados al corregir esa percepción errónea
es que el emprendimiento es la única fuerza en la historia humana
que ha sacado a millones de personas de la pobreza.
(Aplausos)
Ninguna ayuda extranjera va a emplear de forma sostenible
a 250 millones de jóvenes africanos.
Y los trabajos que estos niños pudieron haber recibido hace 10 años
se están automatizando en gran medida
o están siendo cambiados drásticamente por la tecnología.
Y buscan nuevas habilidades,
nuevas ventajas competitivas.
Buscan nuevas empresas.
Y ¿por qué no hay más nuevas empresas abordando estos problemas globales
que enfrentan miles de millones de personas en las economías en desarrollo?
La razón es que los inversores y emprendedores están totalmente ciegos
a la oportunidad.
Creemos que estos problemas pertenecen a ONGs o a gobiernos,
no a compañías privadas.
Eso es lo que tenemos que cambiar.
Es posible que hayan notado que dejé algo fuera del video
que les mostré.
No enseñé cómo aterrizan los aviones
cuando regresen al centro de distribución.
Y puede que sea obvio para Uds.
Ninguno de nuestros aviones tiene tren de aterrizaje.
Tampoco tenemos pistas donde operamos.
Y debemos poder desacelerar el avión
de unos 100 km por hora a cero en medio segundo.
Y la forma en que hacemos eso
es usando un cable que rastrea ese avión cuando entra
con precisión a nivel de centrímetros.
Agarramos el avión del cielo,
y luego lo colocamos suavemente sobre un cojín inflado activamente.
Esto es una combinación de un portaaviones
y un castillo hinchable.
(Risas)
Se los mostraré.
(Aplausos)
Y podría ser obvio por qué quería terminar con este video.
Quería mostrarles a los niños y los adolescentes
que se alinean en la cerca todos los días.
Ellos animan cada lanzamiento y cada aterrizaje.
(Risas)
(Aplausos)
A veces voy temprano al centro de distribución
porque tengo jet lag.
Y aparezco una hora antes de comenzar la operación.
Y ya hay niños en la cerca reservando buenos asientos.
(Risas)
Y uno sube y les pregunta:
"¿Qué piensan de los aviones?"
Y dicen: "Es una ambulancia del cielo".
Lo entienden.
Quiero decir, lo entienden mejor que la mayoría de los adultos.
Antes pregunté:
¿Quién va a crear las empresas de tecnología disruptiva de África
en la próxima década?
En última instancia, va a depender de estos niños.
Ellos son los ingenieros de Ruanda y África.
Ellos son los ingenieros de nuestro futuro compartido.
Pero la única forma en que pueden construir ese futuro es si entendemos
que las empresas que cambian el mundo pueden expandirse en África,
y esa tecnología disruptiva puede comenzar aquí primero.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)